الدبكه هي مش بكثره الحركات الدبكه حسب
مين اللي واقف اول شيء لازم يكون عنده
يعني الكاريزما اللي هو جاي يلف النظر
فيها يكون عنده الحضور يكون عنده الهيبه
يكون عنده الاحترام الاحترام كثير مهم
بالدبكه المواصفات بس يكونوا موجودين بشخص
عم ذبك لو دبك نفس الحركه ساعات العالم ما
بتمل
منه
[موسيقى]
انا منور فندي من لبنان من منطقه كب الياس
من بك انا مؤسسه فرقه دبكي وقائده فرقه
دبكي اللي هي تتالف من 35
شبه انا صديقتهم واختهم قبل ما اكون
مديرتهم ومؤسسه الفرقه ومدربته لا وقت
الشغل عندي الشغل شخصيتي بتكون كثير حاده
فيه
طبعا نحنا مجتمع شرقي والدبكه كانت معروفه
انه هي الدبكه وبعد معروف الدبكه كان انه
هي رقصه للرجال اول ما انا بلشت كانت
العالم تستغرب انه بنت عم تدبك انا كنت
صغيره يعني 13 سنه العالم بتقول عني ما
بعرف بتقول عني المهيوب المحترمه اللي هي
الالقاب اللي اللي حلوه بس تنقال لحد عم
يدبك بعدين شوي شوي لقيته عم تتقبل موضوع
انه بنت فكره انه انا مثلا بنت عم بدبك
على الاول وعم بعطيها كيف بقول لك اياها
عم بعطيها
حقها بس ادبك انا بدبك بعالم ثاني يعني
انا اذا لاحظتوا على اغلب الفيديوهات عندي
انا بكون غامضه عيوني وعم بدبك انا عندي
شيء اسمه عشق للدبكه عشق ل موسيقه الدبك
انا بس ادخل على الفرح طبعا نظرات
الاحترام للناس الي اول شيء انا بكون
فخوره بنفسي فيها فجاه بفتح عيوني بتطلع
عليك الناس كلها حوالي مبسوطه واقفه عم
بتصور تيجي حجه كبيره بالعمر مثلا تبوسني
براسي تدعي لي اختيار كبير يجي يجي يدعي
لي يقول لي الله يخليك به الهمه فهذا
الشيء طبعا بكبر مني هذا الشيء بكبر
القلب بدي اخلي الدبكه توصل لاصغر بيت
لاكبر بيت بالعالم يعني انا بدي كل ما
اوصل لمكان فرجي الدبكه العربيه والدبكه
لبنانيه بدي فرجيه جمال الدبكه اللبنانيه
قديش حلوان كل بلد راح ازوره راح اترك فيه
بصمه اسمها منو فندي للدبكه اللبنانيه ان
شاء
الله